Hi, my name is Mattro Wind, in this talk I will take you through my journey into Emax
themes.
I am a long-time Emax user, I started using Emax since version 21.
The goal of this talk is to inspire more people into making themes, maybe you are already
making themes, in that case I hope you could find some tips and tricks in this one.
I will basically go through all the themes that I created, but I think the most important
thing here is to understand why some of the colors are picked and the motivations behind
them.
So the first theme I created is called DivinT, it looks like this.
The inspiration for this one is a website called DivinTart, basically I just used their
color palette from their design.
It was a community for indie artists, I was really into that back in the day, so that's
that.
Otherwise nothing special.
The next theme I created was called FlockUI, it's Imelpa, and let me just show you, FlockUI.
So, yeah, that's how it looks like.
So, but where did the colors come from, so I understand that I will need to take you back
in time, to where iOS 7 was released by Apple, that was a big deal, because that popularized
the idea of FlockUI color designs, sorry, FlockUI designs, and after that everybody follows
you to change their design of their websites and applications to use some sort of flat UI
design concepts.
And about the same time there came a website called flatUIcolors.com, it hosted one color
palette, and that was really good.
So I picked that as the basis of my theme, and initially I named it flatUI, but that name
was taken in Imelpa, so I just renamed it to something random, FlockUI.
This one is called flat, to understand why I need to create this theme, it's because I thought
some of the colors in FlockUI was standing out too much, like the green here, so this one.
I thought this is too bright, just a little bit.
So I thought I needed way to pick some colors that are about the same lightness, essentially.
So how do I do that?
The answer is to go into a color space called lab.
Now normally you do color working RGB, right, which is red, green, and blue.
It doesn't tell you a lot about lightness.
If you do a pure blue, it actually look a lot darker than a pure red or a pure green,
so that doesn't work.
But in lab things are different, because one of the channels is L, which is lightness.
The other two channels are ANB, which are just for the colors.
This is great, because I could just fix L, meaning I fixed the lightness, and then I can
vary ANB however I want.
The color will stay roughly in the same lightness, which is exactly what I wanted.
So for that, I created a Mac app, where I could just fix lightness, like I said, and then
I could click on this colorful thing to pick a color, the app will pick another 5 according
to some pattern.
And then I could just, like, hard code these colors in EMAX.
Let me show you why I think lab.
Yeah, not very different from flock UI colors, which is intentional.
But the idea here, again, is all the colors will be in about the same lightness, which I
guess it was, so yeah, so this one was a success.
I used it for a really long time, and then I got bored.
So I needed something interesting.
The idea at the time was then to create a theme that doesn't have any colors, essentially,
the gray scale theme.
So I called it nothing, it is also EMAX.
It looks like this.
Yeah, like I said, everything is gray.
There's no color, but to my surprise, this is actually very usable.
I didn't have any problem in readability, I didn't have any problem in distinguish, you
know, different elements in the code.
So a big surprise and also a big success, actually.
And then I got bored, then I just decided to install a whole bunch of themes from NOPA, and
every time I start EMAX, I just pick a random theme.
There are some caveats to that, which I don't want to get into.
But let me just show you why a random theme.
So it picked one for me, and then it picked another, another, so yeah.
It's an interesting setup.
I'm still using this setup today, actually, a good one.
Wars of text.
Now the final theme I want to look into, which is the latest, is called Monte Carlo.
First idea here is to bring the idea of picking a random theme to the next level.
So this is just one theme that generates a random color palette for me, every time.
Not in NOPA, because I'm not completely satisfied.
But anyway, how would I pick a random color palette?
The answer is, again, to look at a different color space.
In this time is called HLC, which is hue, lightness, and chroma.
So hue is just colors, red, green, blue, or yellow, whatever, lightness is lightness, chroma
is saturation, essentially.
This is great because I could fix both lightness and saturation, and only vary in hue to pick
my colors.
Now the problem is, once I have the color palette in HLC, how would I convert it to SRGB?
Because MX only knows about colors in SRGB.
The answer here is to go through another color space called XYZ.
This is an extremely important color space, because basically all other color spaces are
defined on top of XYZ.
So you would have transformations from XYZ to all other color spaces.
Now if you invert these transformations, you could go from, for example, HLC back into XYZ,
and then go to another color space of you tracing.
So this is how to convert colors between color spaces.
In this case, I have to convert colors from HLC to lab, and from lab to XYZ, and from
XYZ to SRGB.
So this time, the conversions are all done in MX list.
And I have the code in here in this URL, you could take a look, or you could actually just use
maybe some package to convert colors.
Anyway, let me show you how this works.
So in this case, I could apply theme Monte Carlo.
So this is now a random theme actually.
Well, a theme with random colors, because I could apply the same theme, and you would
look different every time.
I could also look at the colors it picked, you know, as a list of colors.
I could also look at this like fancy chart of colors.
This is too small.
So let me show you this.
So basically the same thing, this is actually a cross section in the HLC space.
And the colors it picked are these white circles.
So that's that.
But I, like I said, I'm not fully satisfied because most of the time, the colors are pretty
boring from it.
I could think of some ways to improve this.
For example, I could choose different patterns of the color samples.
But I don't know of any good patterns.
So I need to try things out.
And then another way is probably to use different color spaces like the HSL or HSV.
Again, I need to try this out.
So yeah, there are room for improvements.
If you, if you haven't any idea, you know, let me know.
We can try it out.
So that's the end of my talk.
Hopefully you have some new ideas.
Thanks for listening in and yeah, go create more themes because we can't have enough.
Thanks.
[BLANK_AUDIO]